Welcome everybody
to the inaugural NIL
Summit and NIL Awards.
In July, 2022, Atlanta hosted
what might sound like
a boring legal seminar.
A conference on the new rules
around name, image,
and likeness in sports.
But far from dry and academic,
the first annual NIL summit was, in fact,
a flashy star studded event
put on at the College
Football Hall of Fame.
And mingling amid the biggest
current and former names
in sports and media, there
was a crucial cohort,
the players poised to redefine
what it means to be a
modern college athlete.
And the winner of male athlete of the year
goes to Chase Griffin.
Among those up and comers,
UCLA's Chase Griffin.
The UCLA quarterback is among the students
becoming as well known for
making deals, as making plays.
And even in that group, Chase stands out.
My name is Chase Griffin.
What's up, everyone?
It's Chase Griffin.
It's your favorite quarterback's
favorite quarterback,
Chase Griffin.
When you look at it as an
empowerment equity opportunity,
it's really been unmatched
in the sports world
for any point in time since Title IX.
Ready, let's go.
After hardly a full year
of name, image, and likeness
deals being a reality,
he already has more than
20 deals with major brands,
venture and charitable groups,
all the while balancing
graduating undergrad
in just two years and
fighting for playing time
on the field.
Chase Griffin out of the gun!
We are joined by UCLA
quarterback, Chase Griffin.
Not just UCLA quarterback,
but name, image, likeness superstar.
I am psyched for this one.
This kid could actually be the President
of the United States someday.
Chase isn't the starting
quarterback for UCLA.
He's not even the backup quarterback.
But back on campus in LA, his
nickname is President Chase.
And after spending a couple
days talking about his approach
to business, sports, and equality,
it's not shocking to think
he might someday hold that office.
His level of focus and
maturity at this stage,
I only wish I had.
If you wanna buy stock in a human being,
buy stock in Chase Griffin.
When it comes to building
generational wealth,
it's not about the money
that you make in college.
I'm very excited that I
made the amount of money
that I made last year.
I am even 10 times more excited
that I know how to make that money.
Summer on any college campus
is mostly for the athletes
who are on lighter,
but still regimented schedules.
Attending classes, working out,
a little bit of hanging out,
and then more working
out on their own time.
Chase is no exception.
The 21 year old is a backup,
albeit an impatient one.
In the topsy-turvy past couple of seasons
dotted with fanless games
and COVID protocols,
he's been able to start
three games for the Bruins.
Griffin with a throw to the end zone!
Wide open again, touchdown UCLA!
Beating Arizona, and narrowly losing
to both Stanford and Oregon.
That was inches away
from Chase Griffin and UCLA
being in full fledge comeback mode.
For Chase, UCLA felt like destiny.
He was born just a few miles away
before his family moved to
Texas when he was a toddler.
But beyond being a sort of homecoming,
the school's history of athlete
activism was a massive draw.
I always expected for
myself to have some sort
of impact that was
beneficial for more people
than I interact with on a daily basis.
And in choosing UCLA,
a lot of that went into me seeing myself
as someone who reflected the same want
to make things better
that so many of the people
that UCLA prides itself
upon being the home for
have done in the past.
The legacies of former UCLA greats,
like Arthur Ash, Jackie Robinson,
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar,
and Jackie Joyner-Kersee
have had a wide ranging impact on society
well beyond the Westwood campus.
Chase reveres these people.
But he's perhaps most
keenly aware of the activism
of a more recent Bruin alum,
the basketball player Ed O'Bannon
Ed O'Bannon, who was the
Naismith Player of the Year,
national champ, UCLA sports
legend is also a legal hero.
I think NIL could be the next installment
where we look back in 30, 40, 50 years,
and God willing, if we give
him the roses he deserves,
we add Ed O'Bannon to
that list of UCLA greats.
O'Bannon, who played at
UCLA from '91 to '95,
initiated a lawsuit that's widely credited
for finally opening up the possibility
of college athletes being paid
for use of their name,
image, and likeness.
He sued the NCAA and
video game publisher EA
for antitrust violations,
arguing that athletes should be entitled
to financial compensation
when schools used their likeness for gain.
In 2014, a judge ruled in his favor.
And then on an episode of The Shop,
surrounded by O' Bannon, Diana
Taurasi, and LeBron James,
California Governor Gavin Newsom
signed the first ultimately
successful legislation
to allow athletes to
receive endorsement deals.
The Fair Pay to Play Act led
other states to follow suit,
and ultimately led the
NCAA in 2021 to relent,
seemingly reluctantly.
NIL payments were officially
allowed as of July 1st, 2021.
Today is the last day
where name, image, and likeness laws
will not be on the books.
And kids will not be, if you will,
not allowed to make money
off of their name, image, and likeness.
Making money from jersey sales
and endorsement deals is
a way for players to share
in the massively lucrative
world of college athletics.
This NIL thing is the wild, wild west.
The NIL change felt like many things
that happen very slowly, and
then it happened very fast.
And I wonder for you, having contemplated
that maybe this was coming at some point,
how prepared were you?
What was your mindset
when the switch flipped?
Right.
I mean, I still think everyone's
trying to get prepared for that industry.
It's still sort of like a wild, wild west.
I wasn't really expecting anything.
I was more just thinking about, honestly,
getting ready for that season, right?
And capitalizing on
everything that was happening.
When NIL hit, and it
turned out I had action,
I was like, oh, okay.
Well, after this Degree
deal, which was fantastic,
I was like, okay, I see how I
can be a staple in this game.
And I see how I can get better over time.
That's why I teamed up
with my friends at Shell.
And then the Shell deal hit,
and then Boost Mobile deal hit.
And then you keep on building, Clearcover.
Like, you keep on building
and you get better in the meetings.
And most of all, you start
seeing where your value
can be best placed in
these new opportunities.
The headlines and
storylines and the aftermath
of the NIL change introduced
visions of instant millionaires
strolling campuses across the nation.
You might think the
NIL Athlete of the Year
lives in splendor,
or at least in one of
those athletic palaces
that put most of our
college dorms to shame.
Well, it's all relative to Chase.
All right, Jason, so-
So, here we are, world headquarters.
Yup, this is where it all happens.
So this is the kitchen right here.
Actually, I really enjoy cooking.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, this gas oven gets
really hot, really fast.
So I make pizzas in there.
This is the best appliance
since the iPhone, air fryer,
you can put anything in there.
I need to do these dishes right here.
So, no trappings of success yet.
More a pretty average college dorm room.
Got my water.
The fridge filled with leftovers,
a well used PS4, and of course,
the requisite Godfather poster.
It's a far cry from the lifestyle
seen in some local news reports
for NIL athletes during this first year.
Bijan Robinson made headlines
with an NIL deal with Lamborghini Austin.
Lamborghinis tend to make more headlines
than Muhammad Ali or Bruce Lee pictures.
Some athletes are living in
mansions, driving Lamborghinis.
As far as I know, you're
doing neither of those things.
I see where you're living right here.
It is, with all due respect,
not a mansion.
Okay.
How much of that is a conscious choice?
And what does it say about
sort of your approach to this?
Right.
I mean, first of all, I look at this,
as like it's my own room,
I got everything I need.
I'm cool with that, I'm cool
with living below my means.
I think it's important to remember
that the volume of financial gain
is completely overstated.
And that's sort of y'all's
fault in the media.
Yeah.
You know, when someone hears
about a $5 million or a $10 million deal,
you gotta report it like, oh my goodness.
people are gonna read this.
A, I think I'd count two things,
like how many kids are
even getting these deals?
Yeah.
And then for the kids
that do get it, how much
of that is in liquid cash?
And how much of it is in assets?
If you pay for a $2 million
house out here in LA
for a kid to stay in, in
college, that's great.
But as soon as they're graduated,
they're not gonna have
the $2 million house.
They're not, yeah.
I say the same thing, you know,
for the kids who who are
driving around in Lamborghinis
and stuff like that, that's awesome.
Like, that's super dope.
And, and I know some of those kids.
But, you know someone paying
for your lease is different
than someone actually giving you the value
of that lease every single month.
You're investing it,
saving it, 401k, et cetera.
I say all that, just to
mention that product deals
and stuff like that are
overhyped by the media.
And they also can land
kids in some trouble,
if they're not paying taxes on it.
That's one of the distinctly unsexy
and easy to overlook
elements of the new rules.
Even if an athlete's not getting
cold hard cash from a deal,
the value of any products given
are subject to state and federal taxes.
So, suddenly what a
player sees as free gear
in return for some social media posts,
actually equals taxable income.
And that requires the
same forms you'd fill out
as an independent
contractor, getting a check.
I made a fair amount in NIL deals,
and I invested all of it.
In my opinion, NIL is great.
Doing all this is great.
Making money now is great.
But the most valuable thing
I've gotten from all of this
is the fact I'll always
know how to make money
off of myself.
All told chase has done more than 20 deals
with major brands like Degree,
Shell, and Boost Mobile,
along with venture stage companies
including Discord, Duffl,
and Creative Juice.
He's also made a point
to work with charities
like the Los Angeles Regional Food Bank,
where he's already raised
funds for almost 60,000 meals.
This is a song by Javion.
I heard the opening, I liked it.
I just took that opening,
and I pitched it slow,
or I think I sped it.
At his desk, when he's not making music,
another side project,
he's either networking with
CEOs or investors he seeks out,
or who seek him out, or
negotiating new deals.
Hey Mallory
Hi Chase, how are you doing?
I'm doing well.
I'm turning on my camera right now.
Yeah, no worries.
This is an average NIL deal.
A brand approaches an athlete
who can help spread their
message to a demographic
they believe the athlete can help reach.
In this case, DirectTV
is looking to market
their NFL Sunday Ticket
to college students.
There'd be two posts,
one post late August,
and one post on the
first week of September.
And the compensation
would be 1200 per post.
Okay.
So it'd be 2400 total.
Right, perfect, are they video posts
or are they, you know, pic and caption?
They can be either.
It's up to you guys.
So that was pretty good.
400 above what they had originally asked.
So, that's a win.
So, yeah, I mean, at this point
after I do a zoom or something like that,
I either chill out, go back to laying down
if I was watching a movie or something,
or, you know, go to YouTube
to start looking for more samples.
♪ This is presidential, Chase ♪
It's a pretty simple interaction
for Chase and for DirectTV.
Negotiated over a couple
of emails and zoom calls
and papered with a contract
Chase will have his dad
look over before he signs.
And Chase, who's made himself
as much of a student of
the new NIL marketplace
as he has of public policy at UCLA,
says he understands why it's working.
A brand ambassadorship with an athlete
is more attractive to these brands now,
as far as return on investment
than even a a post by a famous actor.
If there's any place to learn
that sports are deep in
the hearts of Americans,
it's on a high school
football field in Texas.
Friday night lights in the Lone Star State
might be the gridiron equivalent
of Frank Sinatra's New York City.
Making it there means
you're something special.
Chase Griffin, quarterback,
class of '19, Hutto, Texas.
And Chase didn't just
make it, he excelled.
Let's talk about some
of the top quarterbacks
in the state.
And when you look at that
list, at the top of it,
you gotta talk about Chase Griffin.
I was lucky to play three
years as a quarterback
for Hutto High School,
which is a one horse town.
We've had great success.
And so the town really shut down
and came out and supported
us every Friday night.
Chase right, straight back.
There's CJ right there.
And he's wide open, if he can catch it.
Nice!
He does, touchdown Hippos!
Chase one word to describe
that finish to that game.
God, that's it.
Coming from a town like that,
where football was so prioritized,
it has its pros and cons.
But I think on the pro side,
I learned how to win, how to get better.
And most importantly what it's like
to build a team where
everyone gets better.
Emulating his UCLA alumni
like Robinson, Joyner-Kersee,
and Abdul-Jabbar,
Chase is looking at the
impact NIL will have,
not just for him, but the
athletes that will follow.
When the predecessors
who have come before you
have changed the world
and made life better for everyone today,
you can't help but ask
yourself how the actions
that you're taking now, and
the companies and brands
in the NIL space that you work with,
are all cumulative, really
building something greater
than any of us could foresee.
I've actually, I've never moderated.
So this will be my first time.
It should be fun.
I know my handwriting's terrible.
The last day of the conference,
Chase was asked to co-moderate a panel
with Monique Nelson, the
CEO for UniWorld group.
All right, I'm excited to be here.
UniWorld group is one
of the longest-standing
multicultural advertising
and marketing agencies
in the United States.
The firm works with brands
like Ford, Home Depot,
and Johnson & Johnson
to help reach the black
and brown communities.
And they have big ambitions in NIL.
For UniWorld group, the
idea of this was pretty epic
in that because we serve the undervalued,
overlooked, and the underserved,
we knew that this
particular group of people
would fall into that category.
And we plan on being the premier
practice for NIL athletes
that are looking to do
purpose-driven media advertising
community-level engagement work.
UWG launched a program called the NILE
to help black student athletes
partner with major brands.
But to help them
understand how to do that,
they brought on Chase to serve
as a student athlete
executive in residence.
For me, I do nothing
without tremendous amounts
of data for all of our clients.
I really wanted to be
thoughtful about this practice
being very athlete-centric.
If I were to build it or anyone
on my team were to build it,
it would not have the athlete at the core.
When, you know, you're 18, 19, 20, 21, 22,
the best way to have
credibility is confidence.
And the only way for
confidence, to be authentic.
I'm actually learning on the job.
I'm learning about the brand side of NIL,
but I'm also trying to make sure
that empowerment equity is built in,
especially for black student
athletes in the NIL world.
ROI, return on investment.
Athletes
Both Chase and UWG see NIL deals
as something much more than
making money for students.
It's also a potential investment
in a community long overlooked.
I think we're getting
ready to stock boxes,
trying to feed the people of LA.
A piece of each of Chase's NIL deals
go to his BE11EVE BRAND campaign,
which has raised more
than $13,000 for meals
for the LA Food Bank backpack program.
But athletes giving back is only one side.
I'm here with LegalZoom
to give you five tips
on the NIL game plan.
UWG and Chase believe
having brands investing in the athletes,
especially athletes of color,
can be a force multiplier
for these historically
marginalized communities.
When you look at the
revenue-generating sports,
football and basketball, 88%
of those athletes are black.
So when you're doing stuff
to empower student
athletes in the NIL space,
you're also helping to
deliver on your promise.
Now, student athletes
are not the only ones
who should receive this
help, by any means.
But statistically, by doing that,
you're gonna be delivering
on your mission.
Additionally, student
athletes, on average,
come from lower levels of income.
So, you're also delivering
on that promise.
And a lot of these student
athletes are first generation.
They're first gen college students.
Some of them first gen
high school diploma.
Some of them first time
receiving the amount of money
that they received in their families.
This has been a wild first year in NIL.
We all knew that there would
be bags of cash around, right?
There's always been bags of cash.
There's cash everywhere.
What we know is that
that's not sustainable.
We know that athletics has
an expiration date on it.
So for us, inclusion ultimately means
this is just a part of you.
It is a tremendous part of you,
and we are gonna celebrate
that part of you.
But we also know that
you're bigger than that.
So we wanna empower you to
live past your expiration date
for this part of your life.
And quite honestly have
equity in everything
that you have poured yourself
into as an NIL athlete.
It may still be the wild west days
for the NIL industry,
but in the first year,
about a billion dollars
in business was done with NCAA athletes.
For the early leaders in
the NIL space like Chase,
they're striking a precedent
for athletes that follow them.
And that's important,
because collegiate athletes
don't have that much time to profit.
Only an estimated 2% of NCAA
athletes go on to the pros.
Even the hardest working are often limited
by things they can't control.
For chase, it's been his height.
I'm 5'10" now.
In high school, after my sophomore year,
when I threw for 3000 yards, I
was probably like 5'6', 5'5".
I mean, I could arguably say
I'm one of the best in the history
of Texas high school
football, but you know,
I've gone through the height test
where they'll call you outta class,
shake your hand, look at you up and down,
and be like, "Nice to meet
you, you go back to class."
It's a sad, but timeless story
for student athletes.
And for Chase, his story is something
he's not shied away from,
but embraced when it
comes to his NIL deals.
I'm frequently the smallest
person on the football field,
but I always strive to
be the most impactful.
My middle school coach told me
that I would never play in high school.
Chase's deals with Degree's
Breaking Limits Team
and Clearcover's Inspired Underdogs
allowed him to capitalize
financially from football,
even though last season, he
never saw the field for UCLA.
I play football because I love the game.
I play the football because
I'm a good competitor.
I love to compete.
And I play football
because I'm good at it.
At the end of the day,
I don't play football for my livelihood,
which is important to remember
when it comes down to identity.
I'm myself, Chase Griffin.
As long as I'm that, I got
something in this world.
As he moves into the new season
and focuses more on
football than business,
Chase doesn't see much
of a differentiation
between the two in terms of his mindset.
I wouldn't be surprised if
I wasn't playing football
in five years and was
running fortune 500 company.
But I also wouldn't be surprised
if I was winning the Super
Bowl 5, 10 years from now.
And either way, I'm gonna
keep on working at the tools
that would align myself
and my future with both.
And at the end of the day,
you're always gonna have yourself.
If you can make profit off of yourself,
and know where you add value
in any world you're in,
you'll be able to adapt
and find ways to generate
wealth for yourself.